>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Good afternoon.
I'm so pleased to see you here.
I'm, my David Plylar, I'm
with the Music Division
of the Library of Congress.
And, I'm especially
excited about this program.
It's one that I wanted to do
for a long time, every since I,
I didn't realize that we
had so many manuscripts
of Charles Griffes
in our collection.
So, when I came across
them, I'd always hoped
that we'd have an opportunity
to have these pieces performed
along with several other items
in our collection including
two works by Amy Beach
and then also the Cesar Franck
Prelude, chorale et fugue.
I remembered hearing
Solungga Liu's recording of,
or All Griffes Recordings,
selections of his
major piano works.
And, I was really taken with it.
So, she was willing to work
with me on this program
and put together something that
was really quite something,
so I think you'll be
in for a real treat
when you hear her
play starting at 2.
One of the nice things about it,
it also includes what we believe
to be a world premiere
of a piano transcriptions
of Griffes' of a WC work.
So, I'll say a bit
more about that soon.
But, it's basically a work
that's been hidden away or,
at least, unplayed in public,
we think, for about 102 years.
So, just so you can get
a sense of, kind of,
the scope of our
Griffes collection,
we have two main areas where
we hold Griffes' manuscripts.
One is just kind of the general
ML 96 manuscript collection.
The other one is the Hineman
[assumed spelling] Collection.
We have a number
of Griffes' songs
in German, some in English.
He spent about four years
in Germany and so he tended
to produce those German
leader when he was in Berlin.
But, there's several other works
that he produced at that time
that also have German
titles like the Fantasy
with Ephontisia [assumed
spelling] title and whatnot.
We also have, so the
Hineman Collection,
which is a collection that
came to us with a number
of different manuscripts
already in it
and then also things acquired
to add to it over the years.
So, part of these, of these
collections are number
of piano manuscripts
in his hand.
And, the items that are
in red are manuscripts
that we all have.
One little note about it is that
the Pleasure Dome of Kubla Khan,
where it says two sources, the
manuscript sources that we have
for that are not
the piano version
that you're going to hear today.
They're two versions of
the orchestral version
that was done a bit
later in life.
And, I'll say a bit about that
when we get to that piece.
So, part of what, maybe
before I start, one thing I'd
like to know is how many
of you know Charles
Griffes' piano music?
Okay, well we have some people
who already know this music.
So, I hope you're, well
like, are familiar with it
to the point where
it's something
that you're comfortable with or
enjoy listening to on the side
or something, I don't know.
Lots of times, composers get
into this kind of obscurity
that they don't deserve and
their music is quite on par
with others of the
same time period.
And, just for quarks of
fate, we don't know it
as well as we would like to.
And, that's why it's also
a nice pleasure to be able
to present this music today.
One of the main reasons
that we don't know as much
of Charles Griffes'
music is because he died
so young, at the age of 35.
And, it was an unexpected
illness right at the, kind of,
pinnacle of his, well, pinnacle,
more like in a valley
right before his career was
about to take off.
But he had produced a number
of orchestral transcriptions
of piano works that
were really taking off.
So, Pierre Monteux of the Boston
City Orchestra performed the
Pleasure Dome of Kubla
Khan to rave reviews.
They played it again at Carnegie
Hall a bit later in that year.
And then, shortly
thereafter, he was,
that was actually the last
time that Griffes appeared
in public was at that
Carnegie Hall Concert.
And then, he was too sick
to travel after that.
But, shortly later, Stokowski
in Philadelphia premiered
several transcriptions
of his earlier piano works,
some of which you'll hear today.
And then, those were
well received.
But, he was never
able to hear them.
So, it's kind of a sad story.
But, while it is a, you know,
it's obviously not a good thing
that we lost him so young,
there's really quite a lot
to celebrate about
what he was able
to accomplish in
so short a time.
He, and, you know, speaking
to the pianist today
about these works, and, one
thing that she really brings
out is that she doesn't feel
like he ever repeats himself.
There's this element of,
while he's often described
as an impressionist, a romantic
impressionist or something
like that, he's also very much
in a Vanguard composer
for the time.
And, he's always experimenting
with what he's doing.
And, I think that you'll find
that, across these pieces
that we're going
to listen to today.
So, we're going to just take
a kind of a quick survey.
I'm going to show you, we'll
focus on the main piano works
that are going to
be performed today,
but also play you
just the openings
of a few other movements that
you're not going to hear just
so you can kind of get a sense
of the breadth that
he has to offer.
Solungga also, very kindly,
allowed me to use her CD.
So, this is her recording.
So, it's nice, and I have
her permissions to use it
which is always a pleasure.
So, the pieces that, he wrote a
lot of works in his short life,
many of which are
short and small.
The pianos not, that's
at the end there,
is not his firs sonata.
There are a number of
others sonatas unpublished
and they're the, they're his
Biographer, Donna Anderson,
has been working on creating
editions of these other things.
She is one of the people
who clears the edition
of the Pleasure Dome of Kubla
Khan for piano in the 90s.
But, these things are
not readily available
with the exception of the
Three Tone Pictures Opus 5,
the Fantasy Pieces Opus 6,
and the Roman Sketches Opus 7.
The sonata's also
very much available.
And now, since the
90s, the Pleasure Dome
of Kubla Khan is available.
The other pieces listed
there that I'm not going
to really play anything
from, Winter Landscape,
De Profundis, and the Legend.
And, there are a number of
other smaller little pieces.
They're just examples
of character pieces
that are worth just
checking out on your own,
if you find this
music interesting.
One of the things I
admire about Griffes,
beyond just liking his music,
is that he was a very avid
and active and successful
transcriber of his own work.
So, the Three Tone Picture, of
which we're going to hear two
of them during the concert, he
transcribed twice, once for Wind
and Harp, Winds and Harp and
then another one for kind
of a dec tech plus piano.
So, Five Winds and Five Strings.
If you can hunt them down,
they're really worth listening
to, they're quite something
and interesting to hear.
So, starting with the Lake at
Evening, this is, I'm just going
to play the opening of it so you
can get the sense of the kind
of placid and beautiful writing
that Griffes was known for.
Sorry, it's not set up.
[ Background noise ]
[ Music ]
So, you have to forgive me for
stopping, [inaudible] here.
So, you know, one of the
techniques here is to keep kind
of a pedal point pitch going.
The pitch changes a couple of
times throughout the piece.
But, you basically have this
gorgeous melody that's maybe
reminiscent of [Inaudible]
towards the center
of the piece which,
in turn is reminiscent
of Chopin Nocturne A Flat Major.
But, the it's just kind of
a perfectly formed piece.
And so, I think that you'll
enjoy that as an opener.
We're not going to hear
the Vail of Dreams.
But, I also feel like you should
hear this, just the opening
of it, to see what kind
of a different type
of work this is already.
All the works that we're going
to hear today are composed,
were composed between
1910 and 1919 in terms
of including revisions.
So, it's really a short
period of his time.
So, just bear that in mind
as you hear the different
varieties.
[ Music ]
So, all these works
that have these kind
of easy going beginnings
in terms of just getting us
into the sound world play,
he tends to push the
pianist quite a bit
as the pieces progress.
So, they, not only is there
interesting development
of the material itself but
it also is demonstrative
of his mastery of the
use of the keyboard.
He was a pianist himself.
And, it would've been
interesting to hear him play.
But, you can already hear
that this is starting to work
into a different sound world.
And, it's still doing sort
of a peddle point type of,
in this case instead of a
single pitch, we're looking
at chords that are repeating.
[ Background noise ]
We will hear the Night Winds.
And, this is one where I think
it's worth taking a listen
to the version for winds,
strings, and piano just
because it's a kind of
interesting orchestration.
Here, one of the things,
and there's lots of examples
across the literature of
works that evoke, you know,
running streams and blowing
wind and stuff like that.
So, there, it's hard
to do something terribly
original along those lines,
especially when you're writing
already in the 20th century.
But, he does something
interesting here with the way
that he divides up the pitches.
You'll notice that it's using
stacked 4ths, sometimes they're
in 2nds and stuff like that.
But, he tends to limit
the gamut of things
to still they're basically
a modified triadic kind
of a thing.
And, eventually, they change,
as you can see even by the end
of that first page,
there's chromatic,
chromaticism is introduced
or not.
But, it's, what the effect
is, at least to my ear,
is it turns back a kind
of wind motive into,
it almost doesn't
matter what it's doing.
You'll aurally recognize
it as the wind
that was at the beginning.
So, you might sense that
there's lots of accompaniment
that goes along with
the melody that arises
in that second system there.
But, when it returns
to that wind music,
you'll immediately know it.
And, it's because
of the pitch content
that he chose, in my opinion.
So, let's hear a
little bit of that.
There's also this one, we
won't play it to this point,
but there's a remarkable change
that happens at the end of the,
towards the end of the work
where he goes into E flat minor.
And, you can see these just
kind of bare chords in the base,
not bare but they're
just kind of suddenly,
I think it's even marked
in stereo so they're,
and you still have the wind
kind of coming back above it.
But now, it's in this context of
the settled E flat minor chords
which never go away even
though he moves away, kind of,
he wobbles around
a bit harmonically.
So, it's a bit on
the progressive side.
Here's the opening of that.
[ Music ]
I always hate to stop.
But, you'll get to
hear it shortly.
[ Background noise ]
The next pieces that we're going
to represent on the program are,
we'll do the complete
set, I won't be,
but the pianist will be
doing, thankfully not me,
the Fantasy Pieces Opus 6.
And these, these ones are
more, it's a Barcarolle,
a Nocturne, and a Scherzo.
We have a, hopefully I'm
not misremembering this but,
we have the Barcarolle and
the Nocturne manuscripts.
And, originally it's, well
that's the other piece.
These were not always
grouped this way in terms
of what they were going to be.
They kind of coalesced into this
when he was going to get them,
trying to get them published
by Schirmer, and in particular,
1915, 1916 this period when he
was able to convince Schirmer
to actually publish
his piano music.
They have already published,
earlier, I think it was early
as 1910, 1911 something like
that, a few of his songs,
they've added a few
more songs after that.
But, it actually took a letter
from Busoni to convince them
to take on his piano works.
And, thankfully, they
did because they're,
this is one of the ways we have
some good editions with these.
One thing I didn't
notice, but you'll find
in the program notes, once we
get them, is these descriptions
that he would attach
to each of these.
In this case, it's a poetic,
it's actually, it's from a poem
by William Sharp which is also
is the poet who's pseudonymously
is known as Fiona Macleod.
So, they have some songs that
use his, her texts as well.
One of the things I just want
to point out about this piece,
and maybe I'll try to,
this is a longer work,
I'll see if I can
get to the right spot
to show you the second
part of it.
This one actually
really reminds of Busoni.
It strikes me as something
that Busoni would do.
So, an Barcarolle kind of
Italianate type of music,
the main melody that you see
there just simply by itself,
if you just look at the pictures
there basically there's a whole
tone scale.
So, the E natural is
the unexpected one,
if we're thinking in B flat.
And, not to get too technical
about it or anything, but,
what's interesting is he turns
something that's so simple
and lovely into something that's
quite different which is that,
on the right side of your
screen, you'll see basically
and A minor arpeggio's in the
base, just very straightforward.
And then, on the right hand,
you'll have this
stressed mark melody
that uses the same pitch set.
The B flat, just think of it as
an A sharp, it's just another,
sorry, another whole
tone grouping,
but in a different key.
So, you're not hearing,
well it's not really a
key, it's this whole tone.
But, you start to hear it as
this kind of jostling things.
But, it's a really beautiful
effect and quite something
as kind of just an eerie
moment in the work.
So, here's just a, to give us
a sense of that let's hear it.
[ Music ]
I one to just go back and
skip to that other spot.
I think it's here.
[ Music ]
So, the eyeball method
of trying to find
that is clearly not the
best way to do that.
So, you'll hear it.
Just, it'll be, it'll be clear.
There's just different ways
that he does it in terms
of the just the position
of different ideas.
They're still quite recognizable
and clearly meant to be melodic
and accompanied in a
very traditional way.
But, there's some kind
of cognitive dissonance
that happens there between
what you expect to hear
and what you end up hearing.
And, that's the kind of thing
that I think is really
attractive
about his music,
one of those things.
I won't play this part, but,
at the, towards the end,
and there's another spot
earlier in the piece
where the music is very, kind
of, mixed modal type of thing.
You can see it gets quite big
with these large
combination scale arpeggios
which are really effective
piano writing there
on that second system
and down to the bottom.
But also, that section at the
top with kind of going back
and forth between modes
is quite effective.
The Notturno is another piece
that just immediately goes
into a different world
except that, you'll notice
that the pitch collections
that you'll hear
at the beginning share
something quite in common
with that first piece
we were looking at.
So, if you have the E flat,
the G, the F, and the A,
you're looking at another
collection there whole tones.
So, let's hear the
beginning of this.
And, this is a very melodic work
but develops in interesting
ways.
And, one of the things
to listen for,
when you're hearing
the whole piece,
is the way that Griffes morphs
the accompaniment very naturally
so that it gives what would
otherwise be a too simple
melodic idea, it gives
it lots of space to grow
and still remain
very interesting.
[ Music ]
So, you can hear, you
know, this is coming
from the Chopin Nocturne realm
but also very much
the Debussy realm.
And, particularly, actually,
there's another piece
on this program that
is, quite deliberately
from the Debussy Nocturne
realm, speaking of Nuage,
the clouds were from
one of the Nocturnes.
Griffes has a piece called
Clouds that he, where he draws
on some of Debussy's
ideas there.
I'm going a little bit fast
just to make sure we are going
to get through everything.
There's some interesting
stuff coming up as well.
The Scherzo shows a completely
different side of Griffes.
So, everything we've
been hearing
so far has been pretty subdued.
But, the Scherzo
gets kind of ruckus.
And he, eventually,
he came back to it
in 1919 and orchestrated it.
It's a nice short
orchestral piece.
Really would be very
good as an encore work.
I think I have that.
[ Music ]
So, yeah it's a very
different world.
And, it has a nice contrasting
trio section but still kind
of maintains its energy
all the way throughout it,
if you're thinking of a Scherzo.
This is that transitioning
into the trio like section.
And, the Roman Sketches
are another set.
So it's, the White
Peacock is probably one
of Griffes' most famous pieces.
I'm not sure it's kind of a mix
of what other people know it
as a piano piece or
an orchestral piece.
But, in that case, it's
interesting in both ways.
And again, because he was
such a good orchestrator,
I think it's really
worth taking a look at.
There's some controversy
about his orchestration.
But, I tend to just
admire the default
of whatever the composer did.
It's kind of worth getting at.
And, that controversy
comes specifically
with the Pleasure
Dome of Kubla Kahn.
Well, I'll just say this now,
since we're already
talking about it.
Frederick Stock Conductor made
some changes for a 1928 edition,
this is 8 plus years
after Griffes passed away,
saying that there was some
discussions that he had with him
about changes to the
orchestration that, presumably,
Griffes was in favor of.
But there's, so not
impugning, Mr. Stock on this,
but there's some doubt
as to whether they were,
really would've been
approved by him, had he lived.
So, there's the early edition
that Pier Monteux continued
to use throughout his career,
and, I know that Ozawa used
that edition as well,
the early edition
where you also will hear the
other version of ride through.
But anyway, if you take a
listen to their orchestrations,
you'll see what I mean.
And, there's some
hideous synchresis there.
But that's a good
thing, I think.
I don't like that, if
everybody sounded the same.
So, in any case, we're listening
to the piano version not
the orchestral version.
And, the White Peacock
has a fairly large poem,
and this is actually
the largest inscription
that Griffes uses in this set.
So, just kind of
there on the side,
it's kind of a different
type of peacock
than you might be thinking of.
It's lots of use of words
like pale and not colorful.
It's more like a this misty
blue smoke those types
of things coming up.
And so it, definitely, to
my mind brings the idea
of color to the forefront.
So, this is a great example of
really excellent orchestrating
for the piano as well.
So here, I feel like
Griffes is trying to kind
of channel a combination
of Debussy and maybe Dukas
as you'll hear with just the, if
you, I'll just play the opening
and you'll see what
I mean, maybe.
[ Music ]
Oops this side.
There we go.
[ Music ]
Yeah so that's there.
[ Singing ]
[ Background noise ]
So, one of the things
that makes, I think,
Griffes different in these
kind of impressionistic types
of works than other say French
composers of the time is
that he allows harmonic sound
where it's actually mixed a bit.
So, you notice that the stuff
when it goes to the low F
that you see there at the bottom
in the middle, kind of rising,
arpeggio that turns into
a scale type of thing.
It's sounds to me like it's
in a different kind of world.
And so, he allows those
things to coexist and kind
of explores it at the same
time as opposed to just having
to have a single minded
focus harmonically.
Yet, they still work together.
So, I'm not saying that
it's not a cogent argument
that he's making.
Night Fall, we will
not hear today.
But, just to give a
listen to the opening
and you'll see a little bit
of, not an evolution in terms
of it being a positive
progression, but,
more just where he's going
with that whole peddle tone
thing that we talked about.
[ Music ]
So, what he's doing here
is clearly having to have
that D sharp that's going
to continue in there,
but the context he puts around
it, you know, all the tones
around it, the D and the
E, it's quite startling.
But, instead of it
being like this sort
of big drawing attention
to himself sort of thing,
everything is very quiet.
And, it's kept very much in
this realm of exploring color
and what dissonance
can mean in that realm.
So, it's not longer, it's
not the kind of, you know,
functional dissonance, in some
sense it is, but in the way
that you might see in
some of his earlier works.
[ Background noise ]
We also won't be
hearing this one,
the Fountain of the Acqua Paola.
These are all, all four of these
Roman sketches are using William
Sharp poems, or actually small
portions of William Sharp poems.
Here's just the opening of it.
And, you can see what the
traditions that he's drawing on,
again, for water music, you
know, with, look at the,
what was available
at the time by Liszt
and Debussy and then Ravel.
[ Music ]
So, it changes character there.
But, you'll notice that
that, and this kind of,
even as grouped in forest here,
the sonnet groupings are three
and it's a very kind of
a recognizable thing just
like we had at the Night Winds
earlier, looking at that,
like you recognize the
wind when it comes back.
Well, you recognize them maybe
when you're looking
back straight
on at the fountain
then maybe you wonder,
attention wonders a bit,
but then you're able
to reorient yourself
pretty quickly.
And, that's, it's a, it's
not, I'm not saying this is
like the most amazing water
accompaniment you can come
up with or something like
that, but, it takes skill
to actually do something
that's convincing like that
and doesn't sound hackneyed
or just like, you know,
like an all birdie base, like up
in the stratosphere,
something like that.
So, there's a good deal
of thought that goes
into those types of decisions.
And, it seemed to come
very naturally for Griffes.
[ Background noise ]
So, Clouds we will hear today.
And, this is the one that,
again, has that, a little bit
of relationship with
Nuages Debussy.
Let's listen to just
the opening.
You'll see what I mean.
But, this is, again, a case
where Griffes is really able
to grasp the poetic
idea and run with it.
[ Music ]
So, it's, you can see like, if
you're following through these
and if you're to go through
the order that they're written,
you see the progression, you see
where he's coming
from with each one.
But, they start to sound
like they're coming,
that there's a totally different
composer even though you still
know it's the same composer.
And, that's because
he's really exploring.
Look at the meter
of this one, 7/4.
He's trying things out and
there's kind of a wide scope
that he's willing to explore
including different types
of modal groupings, different
scales, other things like that.
So, he's, you know,
continuing to explore.
We get to the next one,
Pleasure Dome of Kubla Khan,
this is probably
his best known work,
especially an orchestral
version.
I say that because the
piano version, strangely,
was not published until the
90s, as I mentioned earlier,
but also wasn't performed in
public till 1984, I think,
in the Coolidge Auditorium
after received its premiere,
James Tocco performing.
So, it was, that's kind
of a nice connection
that we have here to this.
But, why I said that
that's strange is
because the work
started as a piano piece.
He, I think he began the
work, working out in 1912.
You'll see in the program notes
where he's getting his
inspiration clearly
from the Coleridge poem,
but really just some
particular aspects
of the Coleridge
poem, Kubla Khan.
And he, so, he's working
it out on the piano,
he plays it for his friends.
It's a different
kind of feedback.
He's continually working
on it for about three years
or so till 1915 or so.
He tends, he keeps
making improvements.
But, he hears from two
particular sources that may be
or two bits of feedback
that push him
to make an orchestral version.
And, one of those, again,
is attributed to Busoni
who apparently listened to the
work and then said, you know,
maybe that's an orchestral
piece.
And so, he took that to heart
and he made the orchestral
version.
Again, we have, we'll have the
two versions, we only have one
of them on display today
for space reasons, but,
you'll be able to see
what that looked like.
And, that was still very
much a developing work.
But that's, again,
the piece that kind
of made his name just
before he passed away.
The piano piece itself,
though, is, I think,
I don't know the people
who like Griffes like it.
But, I think it's undervalued
in terms of its significance
in terms of piano writing.
He is really successful
in orchestrating
well for the piano.
And, that's something I
think that you'll hear
with this performance today.
And, just to give you a sense of
that, we're just going to listen
to the opening of it, which
starts kind of in the depths
of the base and then kind
of builds out from there.
It's sectional in nature but it
always has this sort of return
to some of these ideas that are
put forward at the beginning.
[ Music ]
I'm sorry to stop
it for time sake.
Also, we have a little bit of a
sound trouble earlier, so it'll,
it sounds much better
with a live piano, so,
you know, much fuller sound.
So, this piece is interesting
for a number of reasons.
But, it's a particular
importance to this pianist
who has some Mongolian heritage.
And, in fact, this is a
photo that she gave me
that her mother took and
put into a book, Muren Hsie,
and she's a well known Mongolian
poet who writes in Chinese.
This is from one of her books.
This is actually some
of the ruins of Xanadu
with the summer palace
of Kublai Khan.
And, here's another
example of things.
So, she actually
sent these along
so I could include them just to
give you a little glimpse of,
there's other things that you
can find on line to take a look
at the actually historical
Xanadu.
In any case, there's this
sense of expanse in this work
that I think comes
through very, just as well
in the piano version as it
does in the orchestral version.
And so, it really, I think,
is something to experience,
if you haven't heard it before.
And, if you have
heard it before,
it's a new experience again.
I'm just going to play
you, oops, a little bit
of one other very
significant Griffes piano work
that we're not going
to hear today.
We considered the
idea of programming it
but it's just too much.
So, we're already, the
first half, by the way,
is much longer than
the second half.
So, it's just the way
that it worked out.
But, I wish we could've put
the sonata in there, but,
just so you can see where he was
going towards the later years,
1917, 1918 I'm going to play
the beginning of each movement
so you can get a sense of it.
[ Music ]
So, you can still sense
that lyricism that's been
present the entire time.
But, it's a much more free
lyric, lyricism when it comes
to tonality and harmonic
language.
Here's a little bit of
the second movement.
[ Music ]
Stop it there for time.
That movement Griffes
would orchestrate as well
as an orchestral
movement called,
I think he called it a Nocturne.
And the final movement.
[ Background noise ]
I don't know if any of you
heard in there a little bit
of Prokofiev 7, the 7th sonata.
I do.
>> The last movement?
>> Yep.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah there's some
similarities there that,
I think, are circumstantial.
But then there's,
let's see, yeah,
so this sonata is well
worth getting to know,
it's worth taking a look.
You can just see
he's very much moving
in a more modernist trajectory.
The other pieces also, at
the time, were considered
to be modernist as well.
They really sound a bit
more familiar to us just
because we've had the
innervating century
to get used to those sounds.
Let's see, I think, yeah,
last thing I think I have
on here is just kind
of an interesting little
story about a piece.
I don't have any examples of it
because this is the piece that's
going to be premiered today.
So, this is a version
of the central movement
from Iberia Image for
orchestra Debussy.
I'm not sure what did
that, but, anyway,
so this is just the cover
page of the manuscript
that he transcribed in 1915
after hearing the work.
What's interesting is that he
didn't actually like the work
that much with the exception
of this one movement.
So, he really took to it.
Then, sorry for my washed
out photo here, but,
you can see just that it's a
meticulously done transcription.
And it's, Debussy himself did
not do a solo piano version
of this work.
But, Duran commissioned I think
Muran and the other people
who have done solo
piano versions later
that are much easier
to play than this one.
However, the difficulties
are worthwhile, I think,
we'll see what you
think after hearing it.
But, almost throughout
the entire work,
he keeps it separated
onto three stage just
to be able to keep voices clear.
And so, that's one of the things
that's difficult to navigate
but interesting to navigate.
So, what's kind of
cool about this,
and I hope that maybe you can
let people know about this as a,
if you find this
interesting, is that I came
across that transcription, that
manuscript when I was looking
through just the
Griffes materials.
And, I noticed, it was
catalogued, but I noticed
in the literature it said that
the piece was no longer extant.
So, thought there was a
mistake, it was a mistake.
It in fact was extant, it
was existing right there.
But, because of that,
nobody knew about it.
And, that's why we're
doing, Solungga was willing
to learn it and put it together.
And so, I made this version
for her at first of the,
an engraved form of it.
And, what's kind of cool
about it is we're going
to put this online and probably
as an attachment on the blog
so that anybody who
wants to download it
and play it themselves
can do so.
So, we're hoping to do
that next week or so.
But, so if you want to, if
this is something you want
to just take a look at
yourself and play through,
you're more than welcome to.
And so, it'll be
available that way.
Yeah. And so, I think
I'm going to stop there
because that's the
end of my talk.
But, thank you so
much for coming
and I think you're going
to really enjoy it.
And, I'm happy to take
any questions if I can try
to answer if anybody has any.
>> Did you engrave that?
>> If you can wait
for it yeah, yeah.
I'm sorry, just to record it.
Can you ask a question.
>> You engraved that
right, that was my question.
>> Yeah, yeah, that's it.
Yeah. Anybody else?
[ Inaudible ]
Well that's a tough, I don't
know that I'm really equipped
to answer that question.
but, what I can say is that,
you know, that particular year
that you're talking about
also had a pretty big impact
on both this composer
and other composers,
especially Cesar Franck,
we're thinking of Tristan.
And the emergence of that,
basically, I mean you can start
to see changes in lots of
people's music that come right
after their first hearing
it once they've got a chance
to hear it.
>> [Inaudible] he was actually
[inaudible] produce a movie
and when that boy [inaudible]
was exiled to Switzerland,
he was hiking [inaudible],
that's what influenced him
23 years later, [Inaudible].
And, I'm sensing
these [inaudible] sort
of seeing this recurrence.
>> Yeah, I think I see where
you're going with that.
The, what I can say
is that, I mean,
really there's all
these major histories,
especially literary histories
of the type of romanticism
that goes into these
things coming at the turn,
at the end of the 18th century
going into the 19th century.
And, music starts to kind of
catch up with it and then kind
of intermingle with it as the
century progresses in ever,
you know, inventive ways.
I actually don't think that
that every really stopped except
for in certain types, you
know, Vanguard moves away
from referential types of
music or art production.
But, I think it's
right on to say that,
especially at this time,
if you're looking at,
I don't like the
term salon pieces
because it's a bit diminutive.
But, works that are character
pieces, maybe be a better,
character works for a
solo piano that have a tie
to a poetic source,
which, in turn is, usually,
some relation either
some love or nature,
it's very much following
in that romantic path.
And so, in that sense,
impressionism is romanticism.
Everything, it's all,
all the isms just kind
of blend together so.
Sure, sure.
[ Background noise ]
>> Did you say that
the manuscripts are
on display right now?
>> Some of them will be, most,
yeah, a good number will be
in the lobby as you enter
the Coolidge Auditorium.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, so you'll be
able to take a look.
[ Background noise ]
All right, well,
thank you so much.
Oh wait there's one
more question, sorry.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah.
>> And it's this open
[inaudible] long space very
different than, very different
sound than I think a lot
of other American composers.
>> Yeah. There's a, you know,
that's a good observation.
Have you heard his music
before or will this be?
So, one thing you'll find is
that he, as the pieces progress,
they tend to get more
chromatic or more,
just a bigger type of sound.
But, that sense of spaciousness
never goes away, I find,
in most of the pieces.
So, that's a very good
observation and it's definitely,
there's definitely a sense of
him setting that kind of space
in which that music can
take place in its best way.
And it is, I think that the
unique thing about it is,
I mean lots of composers do that
but rarely do they do it so,
with such consistency across,
even though it's quite
different music in each one
across this different works so.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. You know, that, a lot,
[inaudible] a good example.
And then, there's, of
course, a religious component
that tends to come into it.
But, I think in, for me,
with lots of these kinds
of musical evocations,
religiosity and any type
of spiritual component
regardless of any sort
of doctrinal relationship
just comes through in a way
that composers think
about this music.
So, I think that definitely
is a good observation
that comes through.
One last thing I should say is
that I didn't hit the
Beach in the Franck.
We had a really nice talk
earlier today by McCauley Kate
and Miller about
our Beach Holdings.
And, if you don't
know about those,
we don't actually have
a Beach collection
but we have the A.
P. Schmidt Collection
or archive rather that's a,
that was her main publisher.
And so, we have a number
of manuscripts and copies
of manuscripts as well as
other types of manuscripts
with beach at the library.
And, it's her sesquicentennial
celebration.
She would be 150, I
think, in last September.
So, if you weren't able to make
it to the talk this morning.
We do encourage you, if you have
an interest in learning more
about Beach, there are a lot
of resources available
at the library.
And, the Franck, I'm not going
to say anything about that only
because it's such
a well known work.
But, it's, again, one of the
great pieces that we also happen
to have the manuscript for.
So, that'll close
out the program.
So, thank you all
so much for coming
and enjoy the performance.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.